OUT, EVEN AFTER 60 COURTS HAD
ALREADY REJECTED EVERY CLAIM OF
ELECTORAL FRAUD THEY HAD
SUGGESTED.
>> SO THE ONLY PERSON REALLY
STILL PUTTING THIS STUFF OUT IN
DETAIL AND AGGRESSIVELY IS THE
FORMER PRESIDENT, JUST PUT OUT A
12 PAGE STATEMENT AND GOES
THROUGH ALL OF THIS AGAIN AND
AGAIN, YOU KNOW, LOOK, EVEN
PUTTING IN SOME THINGS HERE THEY
DON'T EVEN PUT ON FOX NEWS
BECAUSE IT HAS BEEN DEBUNKED.
BUT NONETHELESS, HE IS GOING
THROUGH HERE, LINE BY LINE.
IN IT, HE SAYS, CONGRESSMAN, I'M
SURE MAYBE YOU HAVE HAD A CHANCE
TO READ IT, WE JUST GOT IT.
BUT A COUPLE LINES HERE
APPARENTLY IMPORTANT FOR YOUR
COMMITTEE.
HE SAYS MAGA WITNESSES WERE
INTERROGATED BEHIND CLOSED DOORS
IN ORDER TO NOT RECORD THEIR
OWN, TESTIMONY, YET THE UNSELECT
PSEUDO COMMITTEE HAS COORDINATED
WITH THE MEDIA PUPPETS, ONE OF
THE MEMBERS OF THESE TREASONOUS
COMMITTEE AFRAID OF?
WHY ARE THEY HIDING EVIDENCE
FROM THE PUBLIC AND ONLY SHOWING
INFORMATION THAT FAVORS THE
DEMOCRATS TALL TALE?
I WANT TO GIVE YOU A CHANCE TO
RESPOND TO THAT.
>> LET'S START WITH THIS.
THERE HAVE BEEN EFFORTS TO
CHALLENGE THE LEGITIMACY OF OUR
COMMITTEE AND ALL FAILED IN
COURT.
THE COURTS REPEATEDLY UPHELD THE
COMPOSITION OF OUR COMMITTEE,
THE PURPOSE OF OUR COMMITTEE AND
THE LEGITIMATE AND LEGAL
LEGISLATIVE FUNCTION OF OUR
COMMITTEE.
SO ALL OF THAT IS SILLY.
NOBODY HAS DISPUTED A SINGLE
FACT THAT THE COMMITTEE HAS
REPORTED.
WE ARE A BIPARTISAN COMMITTEE
THAT IS UNDERTAKEN A DEADLY,
SERIOUS SOLEMN INVESTIGATION
INTO THE WORST ATTACK ON THE
CAPITOL OF OUR UNITED STATES IN
OUR HISTORY, THE FIRST ONE TO
INTERRUPT THE PEACEFUL
TRANSITION OF POWER.
SO I UNDERSTAND THERE MIGHT BE
MORE BOGUS, NONSENSE, BS CLAIMS
COMING FROM THE FORMER PRESIDENT
BUT THAT'S JUST QUOTING HIS OWN
ATTORNEY GENERAL, WILLIAM BARR,
WHO HE PRAISED SO MUCH OVER THE
YEARS.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT, HE DID PRAISE
HIM AND YOU'RE RIGHT THAT IS
WHAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL, YOU
PLAYED HIM, SAYING ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT TODAY.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ONE OTHER
THING TODAY THAT STOOD OUT AND
GOT A LOT OF PEOPLE TALKING,
CONGRESSMAN, AND THAT WAS THE
ALLEGATIONS THAT GIULIANI WAS
DRUNK, THAT'S WHY HE WENT ON TO
TELL TRUMP TO DO IT EARLY, THE
CONTEXT WAS THAT HE WAS
PRESUMABLY DRUNK.
NOW, GIULIANI'S LAWYER NOW
DENYING THIS ALLEGATION BUT I
WANT TO UNDERSTAND FROM YOU WHY
YOU FELT IT WAS IMPORTANT TO
INCLUDE.
>> I DON'T KNOW THAT IS IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO INCLUDE, BECAUSE I
REALLY CAN'T TELL THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN, YOU KNOW, THOSE TWO
CONDITIONS FOR HIM.
IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY DIFFERENCE,
BECAUSE WHAT HE WAS SPOUTING AS
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR SAID IN
HIS NUMEROUS WITNESSES CONFIRMED
WAS COMPLETE NONSENSE AND HE
WAS, YOU KNOW, TELLING FAIRY
TALES ABOUT, YOU KNOW, FOREIGN
LEADERS AND DECEASED COMMUNISTS
AND SO ON AND IT WAS JUST ONE
ABSURDITY AFTER ANOTHER.
I THINK IT WAS, I THINK THE
REASON WHY CONGRESSMAN LOFGREN
DECIDED TO INCLUDE THAT PORTION
WAS SIMPLY TO SHOW THAT DONALD
TRUMP WAS BEING ADVISED BY
SERIOUS LAWYERS, SERIOUS
CAMPAIGN ADVISERS, CAMPAIGN
MANAGER, THAT THIS THING WAS
BASICALLY OVER.
THAT IT WAS A HOPELESS
ENTERPRISE AND ON THE OTHER
HAND, YOU HAD RUDY GIULIANI WHO
MAY OR MAY NOT HAVE BEEN
INEBRIATED AT THAT POINT BUT WHO
IS RECOMMENDING TO GO OUT AND
DECLARE HE ACTUALLY WON THE
ELECTION.
SO THAT'S AN ABSURD SITUATION
AND ONE THAT IS REFLECTIVE OF,
GENERALLY, THE PATH THAT DONALD
TRUMP WAS ON.
HE WAS RECYCLING THE MOST ABSURD